jean chagneau propose voyage sans
passeport
voici un petit village de pêcheurs
appelé scheer hama
ce village est située sur la côte
orientale de la péninsule
hiru au sud ouest de tokyo ce port est
fameux car c'est là qu'à bordeaux pour
la première fois un navire américain
ceci arrive à quand le japon était
encore au régime féodal
ce village a une population d'environ
2600 âme
la plupart des habitants vivent du
produit des ventes d'une certaine algues
applet and goods à cette algue est
utilisé dans la fabrication de la colle
de poisson
ce sont les femmes là-bas qui plongent
pour larguer
certaines femmes plus âgées autrefois
pêcheuses elles aussi sont chargés vous
l'avez vu tout à l'heure du travail de
triage à 8 heures chaque matin pendant
la saison de pêche qui dure de mai à
octobre
ces femmes font leur travail l'hiver
elle s'occupe d'un ferme car le froid
les empêche de plongée les hommes eux
tirent les bateaux sur la plage et les
charges de 1 vitime en nécessaire pour
la journée entière
no es tu au bois pour le chauffage et
que selon tôt peut avoir besoin en
pareille circonstance la pêche tout en
goujat est en fait le travail du couple
le matelot est en général le mari de la
paix chorges
les pêcheurs sont appelés des cas tsugi
et les matelots watts hamayde c'est joli
non
chaque jour avant de quitter le port
les pêcheuses pris le dieu de la mer
depuis toujours les femmes de ce pays
plonge pour rapporter le temps où ça ils
ont les mêmes fait mention dans la
littérature classique qui vous voyez
cela remonte à loin
la littérature toujours classique
rapporte que les ancêtres de ces
pêcheuses remonte à la période edo
à cette époque le temps goujat et est
utilisé uniquement comme engrais bien
des gens ont fait fortune grâce à la
pêche du temps vous à ces doigtier fais
en coton durci protège des blessures et
ils rendent de bien grands services
cette femme travaille depuis 40 ans avec
son mari
c'est à dire depuis qu'elle avait 16 ans
à l'époque de sa jeunesse presque toutes
les femmes de ce pays faisait ce métier
c'est avec de l'énorme précaution que
sont nettoyés les lunettes de plongée
gallant leymarie plongent souvent en
premier pour s'assurer qu'il y ait ou
non du temps vous à sur le lieu de la
plongée et évite ainsi une fatigue à
leurs compagnes
elle met des filets et un sac sur son
dos la corde c'est à attacher la
pêcheuse au moment de la plongée elle
est alourdi par une pierre d'environ 10
kg
elle descend fantôme ectoplasme
elle arrache le maximum de temps goujat
dans le minimum de temps
elle peut tenir sous l'eau environ 50
secondes en travaillant c'est long
il lui est difficile de distinguer les
ald les unes des autres au fond de la
mer et de choisir des temps vous a parmi
les autres cependant il faut les
arracher avec précipitation et les
fourrés dans le sac
lapierre sert de poids et c'est autour
d'elle que les algues sont arrachés tout
autour des poissons plus ou moins
effrayant risque d'attaquer les
plongeuses
quant au mari lui il a tort anxieusement
met à l'abri
le signal de rappel voilà elle remonte
et sachez que la pression de l'eau rend
complètement sourd de la plongeuse
les plongeuses travail d'environ six
heures par jour elles font en moyenne 80
plonge et madame suzie qui pour monta
l'instant maintenant trop âgé pour une
telle performance plonge environ 70 fois
ce qui semble déjà un record les algues
sont à une profondeur de 5 à 10 mètres
chaque plongée durant environ 50
secondes x 70 cela fait plus d'une heure
de plonger sans oxygène et par jour
certaines femmes très experte peuvent
tenir l'eau une minute et plus la voilà
repartie
c'est extrêmement fatigant
même en plein été la température de la
mer est ici extrêmement froides moins de
10 degrés au dessous de la température à
bord du bateau
quand la plongeuse reprend souffle c'est
à dire maintenant elles émettent un
bruit étrange
cela provient probablement du fait
d'avoir retenu longtemps sa respiration
voilà l ce show elle se réchauffe et
elle en a bien besoin
madame politique à 56 ans même pas mal
le terrain de jeu favori des enfants et
ce bord de mer
la plupart d'entre eux sont d'excellents
nageurs plongée et pour eux aussi simple
que marcher quand ils seront bras nous
aurons un métier tout tomber
ces jeunes filles viennent de prendre
une lotion de plongée madame siouxsie
leur apprend à mettre des lunettes et le
recouvre le visage avec une serviette
aussi à droite que puisse être une
postulante l'enseignement ne se fait pas
sans quelques difficultés
il lui faudra une année environ pour
être une bonne plongeuse certaines
plongeuse appelé au ta katsoulis travail
seule soit parce qu'elles ne sont pas
encore mariés soit parce qu'elles ont le
mal de mer en bateau
il faut remarquer c'est aussi
l'accoutrement de ces plongeurs une
descente parfaite et il doit tout de
même garder le froid les protège
probablement aussi des roches et les
agenais sont obligés de front g
voici ses plongeuse autonomes dont je
vous parlais tout à l'heure
elles ne sont pas mariés quand je vous
le disais ou alors elles ont le mal de
mer elles doivent tout faire par
elle-même une eau ni bateau me l'est
elles ne peuvent donc pas beaucoup
s'éloigner de la rive
elle plonge seulement de 3 à 5 mètres et
la durée de la plongée est beaucoup plus
brève
des poissons poursuivre les crevettes et
les petites créatures qui se cachent
dans les temps 12 à leur nourriture
préférée ou si les plombs jeux sont
elles aussi pêcheuses
là
certains marins jettent leur ligne
pendant que leurs femmes se chauffent du
feu dans le bateau chacun à son tour de
travail et l'arrachage des tambours à
attirer des colonies de poissons et la
pêche devient extrêmement d'aisé
en dépit de leur dur labeur les
plongeuses garde une santé robuste et
sont rarement malade vers 14h30 quand le
soleil commence à décliner
il fait trop sombre pour distinguer au
fond et choisir les armes
c'est pourquoi cessent le travail
autrefois l'arrachage des temps vous a
été plus aisée en effet maintenant à
force d'être repêché il se fait beaucoup
plus rares
et voilà la journée pour madame défini
que c'est monsieur qui commence après
s'être bien reposé les maris rapporte
les tambourins sur leurs épaules ce sont
eux aussi qui nettoie les bateaux et
tient sur le sable après leur journée de
pêche
les plongeuses se rassemblent autour du
feu et elles se nourrissent de l'est et
deux crus elle va voir entre elles
pendant que l'europe sèche
les halles de son l'invs et
soigneusement car plein d'eau leur poids
augmenter
c'est pourquoi on attend toujours un
quart d'heure ou marché avant des pesées
et ainsi elles ont de nouveau le temps
de sécher ou tout au moins des goûters
les plongeuses très qualifiés a racheté
environ 150 kilos d'algues les moyenne
80 pourrait bénéfices variant de 30
nouveaux francs à 50 nouveaux fin le
conte est fait chaque jour ces algues
sont transportés sur des plateaux tissé
en bambou après kamba elles sont triées
avant d'être expédié à l'usiné de
fabrication de colle de poisson située 1
à faro au nord ouest de tokyo
on les x coule au soleil pendant une
journée
il y en a de plusieurs sortes terry gou
aillerie goods are here à 12 a autrefois
les plongeurs étaient les hommes
maintenant ce sont seulement des femmes
qu'à sa dernière sont paraît-il plus
patiente est moins sensible
une fois que les hommes est mon dieu il
ne nous reste plus qu'à féliciter
ok
ivan chagnaud vous a proposé voyage sans
passeport montage claude le gall ou
script chat noir sont christian oeuf que
l'eau douce ration sonore dominic
palladini réalisation solange péters